good morning believe nation today's
messages have courage over to you mark
and racin we really zero in on a people
are you know two things they sound
simple they're not being very difficult
courage and genius courage is the one we
talk about a lot because it's the one
that people can learn you know courage
courage which is to say not giving up in
the face of adversity you know just
being absolutely determined to succeed
you know is something that you can you
can like force yourself to do it can be
very painful you can force yourself to
do it the genius part is a little bit
hard to force yourself to do you know
courage without genius might not get you
where you need to go but genius without
courage almost certainly won't so the
questions of a two-day is how do you
force yourself to find the courage for
me my quick take on it is I think about
the bigger picture I think about where I
want to go that big dream that I have
and to get they are going to have to get
through a lot of uncomfortable
situations but as long as I know that
I'm trying to accomplish this then it
helps me be more courageous in the
moment now and have overcome the fears
that I have into place but I'm curious
how do you do it how do you force
yourself to be courageous leave in the
comments below and I'll join the
discussion thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and i'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events press 0
morning in espresso give me go